So abstract algebra.
We have words like groups Rings Fields Etc
such and I'm going to show you the others.
works this way
you have a set.
To which some specific actions apply
and then if you add or remove axioms you
then get another set. So for example, we have something called a billion group.
a billion group
a billion group. Does anyone know the synonym for the a billion
group?
A problem with these synonyms. I mean exactly a commutative
group.
commutative commutative
and what is it called the commutative because
we have axioms one to four plus a
fifth.
Axiom
Which is commutative.
simply means if you multiply 8 times B is the same
thing as multiplying B times a
now, of course, it will come across certain sets in linear
algebra where this is not the case.
because for example if you want to multiply a row by a
matrix
Yeah, what am I saying? A vector multiplied by matrix. You
cannot turn them around.
So what is it in if you want to
multiply a vector with a matrix the number of
columns must match the number of rows.
So you can't just commit them around it's
not the same thing. Okay.
But anyway, this is not specific to vectors and
matrices is just
it can apply to different types of sets different types
of mathematical objects.
And then we have a ring.
Let me just copy paste the whole.
Set of axioms.
And you'll see what I'm going with this in a very
shortly.
We haven't we have the ring.
A set to which the following actions apply you have associativity for
addition.
Commutativity for addition there. Is this zero
element.
So there's an element. This is incorrect.
By the way plus 0 is a
A plus zero is it?
Okay.
There is added inverse.
So similar to what we saw with the group, there's an
element the inverse of which will give you.
That one gave us identity. This one gives us zero they
cancel it for here. In addition. They cancel each other out we of
course have associativity. This is from multiplication. So Associated
within Community for addition and the
same for multiplication and then there's Unity.
Like with groups and then there is the distributive law.
Then there is a special type of ring.
Called the integral domain.
And this is a set. It's the type of ring. It
is a set. Of course. Well the axioms 128 but
not seven.
So Unity does not apply to an integral domain.
Then there is the field. This is the word we encountered
when we're talking about linear algebra.
So linear algebra.
Is a type of rain.
With axioms want to wait that has all eight Axiom plus
a ninth accent the multiplicative inverse.
That's what a field is.
Now ideally don't know where these names came from ring. I
remember remember seeing a very fascinating page.
And there was illustration about it forming a ring. I don't
remember unfortunately, but the names
in my opinion, they're not very intuitive.
Like why field?
you know, they're not helpful, but
that's how it is.
now
so I hope it's clear. What I feel is right a field is a set
with
or I should say to which these rules apply.
That seems are rules. So this is the active
means something that is true for all the elements
of that set.
Okay, so to all of the elements in a ring,
you can apply these rules. This is this is
true. Well, why is why it is
even helpful because these axioms will help will
give you confidence.
That whenever you apply such operations to any element of
the set you can be sure.
It will it will hold?
If you're doing things like proofs or if you're
from deleting a model axioms will really help you
get to a solution faster. Anyway, that is
so a field is basically a ring, but we also
have a ninth Axiom the multiplicative
inverse.
so
we will see examples of vectors when
you multiply by its inverse. You will
get the original vector.
This is not something you can do to objects and
In the in the let's say integer number system.
Okay.
So let's return back to this.
linear algebra tutorials scaler multiplication
and this has to be
I will use.
C to stand for component
Yes, I hope we can see that this the ball so that that's a vector. That's a
constant.
Multiply the scalar by the vector you will get and you
will get another Vector you will get a vector that obvious. That
would be a subset at the backer space.
Okay.
and
these are vector.
I will say here that this is a subset of the
real.
number system
and this is a
constant component
Let me now show you.
A linear combination what is linear combination?
linear combination
and let me talk about our
to the power n what does this mean?
let's say
to the power 3
What does this mean? So basically?
You will get a set.
Let's use the word space to be consistent with
linear algebra terminology with any three
letters elements or
components any points all of which belong
inside the real numbers system such that such
that
A B C all of them are in
Are or there is a real number
system.
Okay. So for example, this could be a point
in a three-dimensional space.
Or could just be a vector.
It doesn't necessarily have to be a point on
a coordinate space. It just could be a set with three elements in
it.
So that's what this this means.
So for example R to the power 5 same thing a b c.
d
This should be our.
Okay, so here it says we have so now that we know what
that is.
the linear combination
a linear combination is let's say we have vectors.
And here I'm using the boulders V2 from
V1 to VK, by the way when I see and or k
or some subscript like that either pick the number three or
the number five.
Helps me visualize things. So let's say we have five vectors. This
is a vector 1 2 3 4 5 all of them
are for example three in three dimensions.
Associated with each Vector is a constant.
Which are real numbers so we can see there's no superscript here
because these are scalars.
So what's an example of a linear combination something that
looks like this?
Evaluate this expression.
And you have your linear combination?
Now what's a linear span?
a linear span
is the following
Say we have a vector space.
Basically as a set of vectors A set
containing vectors.
And we have let's say five vectors.
So we have a space.
a vector space V
with elements
V1 V2 all the way to VK
and then we put these vectors inside a set
called X.
Okay, so we take the sequence of values. So they're all vectors. We
put them inside it says inside the set X.
If we apply this linear this linear
span function to X.
Then we will get the following.
We will get a set of the linear combination.
So that's what a linear span is. A linear span is a set of
linear combination if you remember from we talked about self-proven notation.
We set that.
A this is well, and
this is a set with these
elements.
Such that these are
vectors.
And these are the constants.
So linear span is a set of linear combinations.
So it's a basically a set of these.
That's what a linear span is.
Okay.